>> Tucker: SO WE TOLD YOU ON
FRIDAY ABOUT THE INTERNAL
DOCUMENTS THAT ELON MUSK
RELEASED.
THEN THEY TOLD US, SAYING THAT
THIS IS JUST THE FIRST BATCH AND
THEY WILL GET A LOT MORE IN DAYS
TO COME, BUT THEY NEVER CAME
OUT.
THAT IS KIND OF WEIRD.
AND SO WHAT HAPPENED?
WE LEARNED TODAY WHAT HAPPENED,
THAT THIS WEEKEND.
AND THE GENERAL COUNSEL, THE
FORMER FBI GENERAL COUNSEL,
JAMES BAKER, HAD BEEN VENTING
THE DOCUMENTS AND NONINCLUSIVE
KEEPING IN MIND SINISTER INTENT.
THIS SAME JAMES BAKER WAS ALSO
THE GUY THAT HAD THE FRAUDULENT
PFIZER WARNINGS THAT TARGETED
MICHAEL FLYNT AND SO IN LIGHT OF
THE FIRING OF MICHAEL BAKER,
SUPPRESSION OF INFORMATION AND
PUBLIC DIALOGUE, HE WAS EXITED
FROM TWITTER TODAY.
AN AMAZING STORY THAT JUST WAS
OUT.
MAKING SENSE OF IT, WE ARE HAPPY
TO BE JOINED BY THE INDIVIDUAL
FROM THE "NEW YORK POST" WHO IS
JOINING US NOW AS OUR GUEST.
>> HELLO, TUCKER, AS YOU AND I
DISCUSSED ON FRIDAY NIGHT, IT
WAS PRETTY OBVIOUS THAT THE
TWITTER FILES THAT HAD JUST BEEN
RELEASED WERE MISSING A CRUCIAL
ELEMENT.
AND THAT WAS THE FBI.
WE HAVE SURMISED THAT SOMEHOW
ELON MUSK HAD REDACTED IT OR
SOMEONE HAD WITHHELD THE
INFORMATION.
>> Tucker: MIRANDA, YOU WERE
ONE OF THE FIRST TO TALK ABOUT
THAT, AND YOU SAID SOMEONE HAS
TAKEN OUT THE INCRIMINATING
STUFF.
>> WE KNEW THAT THE FBI HAD
PRE-BONKED THE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS BEFORE IT CAME OUT
AND WE TOLD HIM TO EXPECT A PILE
OF RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION AND
TWITTER WAS TOLD BY THE FBI THAT
WE KNOW TO EXPECT THAT IT WOULD
BE IN OCTOBER THROUGH HUNTER TW.
AND IT WAS PRETTY OBVIOUS WHO
WAS SUPPRESSING THE
>> IT WAS TWITTER'S TOP LAWYER
JAMES BAKER WHO IS HE JUST SAID
HAD BEEN THE TOP LAYER AND THE
FBI.
ON THE QUARTERBACK OF THE FBI,
RUSSIA COLLUSION.
AND THAT SCANDAL.
AND, HE HAD HAD TO LEAVE THE
AFTER THAT BECAUSE OF THAT.
AND LO AND BEHOLD, HE SHOWS UP
IN TWITTER FIVE MONTHS BEFORE
THE 2020 ELECTION AND LO AND
BEHOLD, ONE LITTLE ELEMENT DID
COME BACK IN THE TORT OF FILES
FRIDAY NIGHT.
IT WAS THIS ONE EMAIL, THAT HAD
THE DATE AND TIME REMOVED FROM
IT.
I WAS VERY PECULIARLY.
BUT IT IS FROM JAMES BAKER, AND
WAS WEIGHING IN ON DECISION OF
THE MORNING OF OCTOBER 14TH
2020.
A FEW HOURS AFTER A STORY CAME
OUT.
AND THERE WAS JAMES BAKER
WEIGHING IN ON THE SIDE OF
CENSORSHIP NO SURPRISE THERE.
>> AMAZING.
AND AS YOU SAID AT THE VERY
OUTSET, THIS IS NOT THE STORY
ABOUT FREE SPEECH ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, THIS IS A STORY
WITH THE CORRUPTION OF THE FBI.
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
>> AND TUCKER, ELON MUSK NEEDS
TO LET ALL THE INFORMATION OUT.
AND LET US SEE IT.
NO MORE